he's still so funny I mean here's the
thing I feel like if someone can make
you laugh I know like you know what I'm
saying Love Changes it doesn't
necessarily fade it just changes I feel
like but like if someone can make you
laugh like that's what we're all looking
for because it's that's always going to
be awesome to be around he is funny I
have to show you this he has such a good
sense of humor here is his Grammy
Campaign which
which you literally have to read all
it's not just the picture he is so
clever with the writing on the side it's
just I think he's a piece of cake when
you're rich
loves needs new feature
he's so funny well the thing is is all
these people were posting their own
things and he's like what is this I know
and he's ripping on it it's funny I know
I think that's so funny so and he also
did this he replaced he replaced their
faces in the house to see if you would
notice I guess with the Jonas Brothers
on like our Fame photos Okay well here's
what I did notice we get People magazine
in the mail and so I saw the magazine
and it was like shredded sitting on the
on the counter and it was a Jonas
Brothers one I'm like I don't even know
what to think about my my kids probably
did something weird with this magazine
yeah right and so then you guys that's
my birthing photo okay that's so pretty
and he had cut all the Jonas Brothers
heads out and put them up all of our
frame photos in the house he's so weird
if weird means awesome I just it I love
that it's just so fun he waited until I
noticed and it took like a couple of
days for me to which says something
maybe not so observant in your household
well there's just a million three kids
and a lot of animals I get it no no I
get it he's he's a really great
prankster and honestly some of the posts
on Instagram if you don't follow him on
Instagram it's quite a laugh sometimes
this stuff is so weird it goes over my
head I'm like I didn't get that one and
then the other ones I'm like I'm dead
you're so funny yeah he is it just you
know seem like you have such a cute
relationship like friendship as well
totally we do we do and um you know he's
a real chatty guy so yeah at the end of
the day when I come home from work and
I'm like tapped he like downloads all
the information to me from the day and
we kind of like he gives me all current
events and his hot takes on everything
and he's he's just great but I left a
note I went to New York last week and I
left a note for my kids because I left
at like 4am and I'm like love you family
I'll miss you guys and he just posts on
Instagram a picture of and he's like I
think my wife left me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
have a great night
[Music]